[Music]
hello and welcome to beautiful geneva
it's such a shame this city speaks
french i'm here at the aiia festival a
crossover between ai and arts and
creativity and uh yeah it's cool to
attend in-person events again and it's
especially cool that they are inside the
borders of the country i happen to be in
even if it's in kind of the part of the
country that we don't regularly go to
[Music]
for those of you who don't know geneva
is at the very very tip of switzerland
switzerland looks kind of like a pig and
geneva is the tail end of the pig though
i like to think of it as sticking a
little middle finger out to france the
aiia festival is a festival that brings
together ai and art it consists of
things like exhibitions artists
performances discussion panels of which
i was invited to some to speak even as a
technical expert on ai the festival
largely revolves around an ai called
chimer or chimera that has been
especially created for the artists to
work with shimer is an integration of
language models image models and audio
models and the artists can interact with
it via a nice little discord chat bot i
was pretty excited to go there to be
invited and to see what's going on in
the world that's outside of my usual
habitat
making difference
this is laura um the the
i think chief organizer actual actual
making stuff happen at the festival not
just programming or
or arting one of them just one of them
nice
so what's the what is the festival all
about if you had to summarize it okay
festival is about how to understand
artificial intelligence with the the way
of art and how to democratize the
comprehension of impact of artificial
intelligence for all people you have
artists here you have kids camps we had
speeches we had panels and so on is
there a theme an overall theme that
pulls through all of it for all of that
the festival is organized by impact ai
foundation and for us what is important
is to see how artificial in intelligence
impact the workflow of
work and environment and who is impact
and transform the work
and for that we are thinking if you take
the the way of art it's more easy to
understand what is the impact for me if
i can see an artist work with ai what
means for me if i don't be an artist but
i work if they can work with ai how can
i do that too and to go away from
from
have fear of ai and to to have the the
empowerment
with these technologies so this isn't
this is we're here in geneva and it's
not over now right until when can people
come and visit the exhibits and it's not
over it's the beginning yeah um the the
festival is um it's continuous until 31
of october october and it's the first
edition next year same time same place
probably we have the second in each
edition and we we will have in probably
five or six years of this type of
festival in all parts of the world to
discuss about the impact of artificial
intelligence for people and for
transform all the society for a society
for good common with ai cool
thank you so much thank you
[Music]
this is this is this is tim technical
chief of the festival could you tell us
a little bit what is humera okay the
idea was that we wanted to provide
contemporary artists with deep learning
tools take artists that never work with
ai or deep learning or really computers
much at all and see if we could actually
make these tools creative i mean as an
engineer when you play with gpt2 or 3 or
j you think this is great it creates
fantastic tests this is so funny but
does it actually work with people who
you know his profession is to be
creative and that's what we wanted to
find out and we had the opportunity to
take the the whole multi-modal set of
networks that we have nowadays so you
can do the text generation but also
image generation using clip and and
diffusion models and you have music
generation with jukebox they wanted to
bring all these together and connect
them as much as possible into a single
entity and provide it to the artist in a
way that wouldn't look like it's their
collab would be something they could
relate to and interact with so you've
made a discord bot yeah it's
fantastic it's pretty it's so proud yeah
so if there is clip guided diffusion
which we've seen in the images there is
also text a text model can can you speak
a bit about how the text model comes to
be because the artists have also told me
that it learns over time and so on which
is is not typical for a if i just use
gpt3 every prompt is independent right
initially we thought we'd we'll start
with gpd3 the the the davinci model yeah
because we needed some kind of data set
to bootstrap the the conversation model
because if you try dbtg or gpt2 as a
conversation model out of the box you
don't really get anywhere you need
somehow to give it enough data to to be
able to with all conversations properly
we did a backstory and a prompt
bootstrap and that got them talking with
gpt3 then after a few days we had enough
data to train gpcg and fortunately
hugging phase had this model integrated
into their tool set around the same time
so it's actually quite straightforward
and then every day we collect the data
set from the artist so the conversations
the generations they've done plus any
data sets it uploaded via the discord
box that we bring together and integrate
into the overnight training and so the
trick is because these data sets are
quite small you want to fine-tune really
lightly with a low learning rate and and
also not too many epochs so 10 15 epochs
you you get enough impregnation of the
data set into the model but not too much
so that it memorizes really everything
strongly i was i was surprised by the
breadth of stuff you got out of these
models there is music there's pictures
there's poems there's also wallpaper
designs yeah it is pretty cool to see
just how much stuff people can get out
of what to us our language models or
convolutional nets or something like
this
this is jonathan
from from the festival dai is a
non-humanoid artificial intelligent
robot although i don't really like the
term artificial intelligence it's more
a machine that can learn
how it works is um it has an actor
critic so the actor tries things so
basically you can activate the motors
there are nine motors one for each wheel
and these wheels are a bit special
because they're omnidirectional wheels
because it it because we chose to put it
in a on three wheels on three axles so
one of the wheels needs to be able to
roll freely in some directions while
you're distracted another three motors
for the axles so the cube can move along
the axles and with the wheels so the
cube the cube can move
the cube can move along
these things yeah exactly okay so it's
got a bunch of controllers like a a
central controller which is a
an nvidia
jetson xavier and then it's got a bunch
of small jets and nanos to do that to
for the cameras it's got six cameras one
on each side so we really made this
complicated for ourselves because we
wanted to make a non-humanoid robot
because we thought it was more
interesting and we were hoping that it
would kind of um prevent people from
projecting onto it so we were hoping to
limit anthropomorphism yeah
that failed
like people project onto any shape or
form or anything
especially if it moves by itself but we
also wanted to prevent it from learning
directly from humans so it can see human
movement it has to sort of transpose it
into its own capacities into its own
body so what do the cameras do they see
where does the image go right now as it
is like we we're
finishing connecting that to the to the
main ai so right now what it does it
helps it recognize objects basically
then it's going to be able to use that
okay so we were working with david
rudraf
a neuroscientist and he's got this um
embodied consciousness mathematical
model theory basically it's kind of a
based on lachen's idea that you build
your personality by and i'm not going to
say this very well but you build your
personality by um what you perceive in
the way other peoples look at you it is
called like
like a little kenyan mirror and they
have a mathematical model of that and we
want to be able to try and um and see
what happens when we put that into into
dice um ai so far we're not when we're
not quite there now it's broken well
yeah that's it i mean every time you
move forward you jump back
you know i mean robotics is a is a it's
a painful uh it's a painful business
but it's also fascinating because i mean
right now it's a small problem right i
mean these two batteries are too old and
they've suffered a bit and they've over
discharged and they've inverted their
polarity which i guess they could have
caught fire they didn't
so now i just need to replace those two
and it'll be back on its wheels so the
active critic works like this it's got
like the actor who tries activating all
of the motors and the critic which
encourages it or discourages it to
continue in that direction as we wanted
it to learn its own movements by itself
we didn't want to give it like
directions like say okay when we tested
it we we turned it on and we said like
we just wrote a short script for to
reward a circle of three meters diameter
and really quickly it managed to like
learn how to do it almost perfect circle
with it and it's quite complicated with
the three wheels like if you try like
remote controlling it yourself it's
super difficult to make it go straight
at all we figured out that it worked and
um we wanted to give it like the most
basic rewards that you could um to
encourage it to discover so we chose
angular displacement we thought that's
great everything's an angular
displacement in this model like when the
cube moves up and down it's an angular
displacement when the wheels are
activated it's an angular displacement
seems fine we turned it on for the first
show and actually nothing happened so i
was talking for like two and a half
minutes it was actually using raspberry
pi's for everything at the time so it
was really slow to boot and and a bit
slow to move but that's the thing the
technology has been moving so quickly
that now it's actually got powerful
brains and stuff anyway here was i
talking to people saying probably
something's happening there's maybe
electricity flowing but not enough and
something will activate soon and after
two and a half minutes like the longest
two and a half minutes of my existence
suddenly one of these wheels just went
and everybody was like wow
you know that was really funny because
it's like when you see a kid walk for
the first time everybody's amazed but
it's just you know it's just not falling
basically for you and catching yourself
but suddenly you've learned something
new and do you plan to have it interact
with humans like with the cameras and
the sonar or yeah that's what we're
trying to get to right now i mean it's
um as it is it can do movements so it
can explore space and um and explore its
movements in the new space i mean it's
really interesting to see what happens
when it's on different surfaces when you
bring it to a new space if it's a carpet
yeah then it's got lots of grip and it
needs um or maybe the carpet bundles up
and it needs to add loads of power so
when it gets onto a
slippier floor the wheels spin but
really quickly actually it adapts to
that
this is uh clear clay is one of the
artists here who
worked with chimera yeah correct rivera
is a language model retrained every
night as i understand
things input stuff back into the af yes
okay there's also an image i think this
is clip guided diffusion no that
makes these images this is also
chimera but okay um
we have the two with the two the two
things one does language and one does
language to pictures right yes and
there's also so the language is both
chatting and generating text it can do
both yeah i struggled a lot how come
i think for the
chatting
it soon came to a kind of end or limits
after which i didn't really know what to
do or how to interact anymore and i
would reset it all the time yeah
yeah i would just spend my time
resetting and again
like this they get a bit repetitive
right and a bit predictable yes but what
i did is that i
gave chimera a text i wrote five years
ago about the character i invented and
the structure of this text is very
repetitive so
then chimera could really produce more
text with my character which was at the
beginning quite good really could have
been written by me and i don't know why
after two or three days it came really
really bad yeah the thing is with
chimera she keeps or she or whatever
um i call hershey because because in
french she marries her okay feminine
yeah the thing is that she keeps
generating dialogues probably because we
interact with her yeah
via dialogue yeah my texts really don't
have dialogues i see she starts by
really understanding what i want or i
mean pretend that she understands what i
want and then after a while she just
invents dialogues that's really not what
i would have written so that's why i
invented this psychobot which is the
psychologist robots my character has
which will
be featuring here when we make the
can people interact with your
psychologist in any way it might happen
for the moment it's only my character
who connects with it and i'm not sure
yet how my character really interacts
with it okay so you don't know what's
gonna happen no
you know there there was a story a few
weeks ago where people built therapists
based on this technology and one of the
therapists told one of the patients to
kill themselves that's actually what
happened when i really used it as a real
okay
well i pretended i was so sad and i was
really depressed and asking if it could
help me yeah and after a while
yeah you just said okay then i think the
best way is to kill yourself
and
that's where i realized i should use it
another way
otherwise this would happen all the time
it's like a real therapist they always
try to get you to solve your own
problems right
it's possessed
i found that concentrating on the
negative aspects of life can be helpful
for feeling better
this this seems very counter to
and
would he do that often that it switches
topics
okay
can learn from itself wow
and olga is your character
and so the therapist would know about
your character what's up with the with
the dresses so this is maria's project
so maria
and she created an opera so they
designed all the opera and the clothes
and the costumes and
the lyrics for the opera together
and so that's the picture pictures
generated by chimera and these are
wallpapers
papers generated by generated by chimera
which i used for my videos people love
flowers on their wallpapers
well
did you say it yeah is that flower
flower pattern wallpaper this is very
artsy i have to say
this is
on youtube we cut at least every three
and a half seconds or so because people
have no attention span all the episodes
are very boring
they last between three and four minutes
and nothing happens except for a
background changing
it could it could you know asmr yeah
exactly
this is the
source of inspiration for my work
actually what's up with the hanging
phone so
uh
to read it better
and this here is tim said it's a stream
of consciousness yes and i have no idea
exactly what is something i haven't
worked on so i think these might be
images that were generated by chimera
morphing into other images or it's just
the process of one image
[Music]
tech
all in all i spent three days at the
aiia festival i was part of five
different panels and it was pretty
intense but it was also pretty cool
i'm not an artsy person at all so this
was a really new world for me and it
gave me a bit of an insight into how
people outside of academia outside of
the field could make use of ai in the
near future it seems like these new
generative models can be really cool as
creative assistance to artists and
anyone having to do creative work so
with all of that i got myself on the
train home i hope you enjoyed this
little trip report and i'll see you next
video thank you so much to the
organizers of the aiia festival for
inviting me and for providing me with
such a cool experience
[Music]